okay here we go you have uh
10 seconds and then we'll be live thank
you right let's make a startling good
evening and welcome to tonight's uh
virtual uh meeting of planning committee
a
my name is danny kendall and i'll be
chairing tonight's meetings uh
meeting in accordance with the rules
that's perfect thank you okay hopefully
there's no feedback now wonderful
uh before we get started if i could just
go through a little bit of housekeeping
i'll be as quick as i can
uh you should have been everybody should
have been made aware um made
aware of the council's guide for
etiquette during virtual meetings
the most important points are uh please
ensure the device you're using to take
part in this meeting is fully charged or
charging at the moment
please ensure that you mute the
microphone when not
speaking it's very important so we can
avoid any feedback then of course make
sure you do turn on the mic as fast as
you can when you are addressing the
committee
and then of course turn it off again
when you are finished uh please also
remember to
make sure mobile phones are switched to
silent or turned off altogether
um if a member of the committee
encounters any problem during the
meeting and you uh
i don't know and you lose con connection
or for whatever reason you please make
your best efforts to rejoin the meeting
as soon as you can if you can't come
back
in uh well it will be you'll be deemed
to have left the meeting
the meeting will continue without you um
as long as it remains court
also please be aware that uh this is for
members of the committee and
any other participants tonight members
of the public the meeting is being
recorded and of course
live streamed uh and images may be used
for
training purposes later
for clarification for members of the
public it was established before the
meeting that all committee members
can see and hear proceedings and have
read
all of the agenda and update sheets
right there we go uh let's move to a
very quick introduction of the
offices please if i if you could just
please confirm your name and role
we go to uh olivia please
olivia quinn community services
thank you mina mina matt
legal services thank you dale
dale barker team leader planners thank
you
uh paul paul thompson planner
thank you uh joseph uh jay brooke
planner thank you anne's lawyer
zoya's off the car planner that's
wonderful
excellent i think we've moved through
that very quickly um
very quick reminder for members of the
committee you all know this of course
but when we do get to the votes later on
please remember to say your name clearly
uh pause for a moment then say clear
four against or abstain and of course if
any member of the committee wishes to
speak during the meeting or ask
question we uh just indicated in the
chat box on the right hand side and i'll
uh try to notice you as fast as i can
right without all being done we can move
to our normal process now uh we go to
item one apologies for absence please
olivia
we've got apologies from councillor adam
that's wonderful thank you very much
uh disclosure of interest please any
members of the committee
councillor dixon uh no but
no no personal interest at all in item
seven
but however i have made up my mind
regarding this application
i will be speaking in support of the
applicant you are the award member for
that one are you not
i am yes that's well thank you tony uh
any other disclosure of interest
no oh yes cow's redden
uh item number six uh sambal
on the ward member i've made uh no
representation and opening
oh chair you're muted gosh sorry there
we go
i'm not used to i've got a new mouse
just so we're clear on that sorry it
doesn't work quite the same as the old
one
i'll i'll get used to it um right okay
if no other
declarations of interest move to the
minutes are you all satisfied with
minutes
of the previous meetings uh there's a
number of them here
is that okay can i take that as an
ascension yeah everyone's in the center
that's great thank you
i will sign those at some point in the
future wherever i get to see the real
hard copy
um right let's move then to our first
item tonight this is item 4 on our
agenda
and that is found on page 23.
so this is application reference 20
slash
01606 slash ful and is for the
recreation ground
rogers lane eddington uh it is for a
wheeled
play area presenting officer paul
thompson
paul you ready to go thank you sure yeah
good evening everyone um good evening
council's good evening guests
um let me just check you can
see
this is that coming through for everyone
perfect thank you
great okay so as the chess said we are
in the center of eddington
um not much to say about that
here we can see the wheel players covers
about 300 square meters
it'll be sighted between the the mother
multi-use games area
and the community centre itself with car
parking trees in between
um there's 40 meters from the
boundaries of the properties to the
north east which if you can see my
cursor is there and about 50 meters from
the houses themselves
maximum height as we can see from this
is about 1.5 meters above ground level
that
section is about here and it's grasped
um this is the view to the north
west or the north and west this is the
view to the north and east
and this is the boundary to the south um
there are two things in my report that
i'd just like to
enjoy your attention to firstly that the
environmental health office of the
council's environmental health officer
does not consider
acoustic fencing to be necessary um on
the
basis of the the noise report we've
received and
secondly that although a lot of
objectives have mentioned
um whether the development is necessary
that's
not for us to determine that's not a
material consideration here
thank you councillor
wonderful thank you for that paul
excellent stuff let's move to our first
speaker then
um hopefully we've got on the line we
should have uh peter
so pete george resident and he's
objecting to the application
mr george you there
i think star six to unmute yourself
mr george are you on the line
he is in german can you press star six
to a mute please
right we're having a bit of difference
should we go to the next speaker
and see if that works we can come back
to mr george in a moment
okay so if we go to our next speaker we
go to the applicant
um in this case it's councillor rich
smith
speaking on behalf of eddington parish
council councillor smith are you
available
oh gosh councillor smith you there
yes i'm here oh now oh thank god for
that
thank you councillor smith welcome to
the meeting councillor smith
um okay good evening and thank you for
having me
um if i could just give you a quick
overview you have three minutes if you'd
uh
stick to those timings at the end of the
three we'll give you a warning in the
last 10 seconds if that's okay and then
please stay on the line afterwards for
any questions from the committee
okay i will do but since i've gone
unmuted you've got very very quiet
indeed i think oh
i i might have got you back okay
over to you yes i have so good evening
and thank you for having me
um i see three main topics highlighted
in concerns expressed by objectors that
i want to address
so on on visual impact it has been said
that a concrete wheel player here is
incongruous with a village scene i i
think that the sighting within the
village is well chosen
to prevent such incongruity we have
the brightly painted steel framed play
equipment at one end of our park space
we have the steel frame and the wire
cage that is our mugger
at the uh right next to the the site and
in between these we've got a significant
modern structure of our community centre
these facilities could equally be set in
the park of a larger town or indeed a
suburban centre of a city um the world's
play area is necessarily modern but is
set among modern facilities and
surroundings and
should not look displaced um on
anti-social behavior which is another
thing that's been cited following a
freedom of information request to
shipstone constabulary regarding its
wheeled play area
using 2019 data of the only seven
instances of anti-social behavior
all under the subheading nuisance within
the postcode there were only three at
the leisure center and only one where
the skate park was mentioned
there were no instant incidents of drug
related reports
there's no reason to suspect that an
eddington will play area would be any
worse
with advice and research epc believes
that sorry eddington parish council
believes that we have
avoided the common mistakes that
increase the likelihood of anti-social
behaviour
we've cited the park where there are
frequent passes by
it's close enough for easy access and
use a disused and hidden skate park is
is one that encourages anti-social
behavior and criminal activity
our youth team which helped design the
uh design the obstacles small enough
to be accessible to novice novices while
challenging enough to stretch and
encourage advancing riders
our professional designers commended
them
for this and then took their ideas and
knitted them to a into a facility which
flows well
and provides the recommended safety
clearances etc
by good design and placement we are
confident that the park
will be used as intended and therefore
valued and that in itself will provide a
natural deterrent to antisocial behavior
finally on noise heading to paris
council has
chosen a concrete design for its
durability but mainly for its reduced
noise
the noise report concludes that there is
a moderate risk of
adverse noise impact for both continuous
and occasional noises
however for the continuous noise it
states that and i quote
this is very much considered to be a
worst case
and for impact noises it says that the
likely frequency of the noise is only a
third of that
in the assessment standard seconds john
finally goes on to note that these will
be
similar to the noise from noises likely
noises from the mugger
and would not be wholly out of context
in the existing ambient noise
environment so i hope that the committee
will see that this is a good project for
eddington and can be allowed within the
rules that you must apply
i humbly ask the committee to approve
our application
that's excellent thank you councillor
smith excellent um
we have some questions uh councillor
harry you have a question please
parish council uh good evening
councillor smith
um good to hear you um i note in the
uh committee report um that your
neighborhood
uh development plan policy la3
the enhancement and expansion of sport
and recreation
facilities now obviously you consulted
widely with the village
could you just confirm what the
percentage
on your referendum was that would be in
favor
of your um neighborhood development plan
that identifies to seek enhancement
of sport and recreation facilities
unfortunately i
haven't got the figures in front of me
um
our clark is the um he's the holder of
the
the all the records on these things i
can forward them to the committee
um as soon as as soon as this is over
my my point is what did did you have
sort of
overwhelming support for your
neighborhood development plan
uh yes the plan was well supported
but i'm afraid i couldn't give you the
actual number that's not a problem
thank you okay i'm not
seeing any uh further questions and chat
so if that's the case i'll say thank you
very much for your time
thank you i don't know how to put myself
back on you sorry
um i'll meet you okay thank you thank
you
okay um okay um waiting
don't worry about it it's not the
easiest thing in the world is it um
right so i hope you heard most of what
we've had so far miss george
uh you have three minutes as i said
you'll get a warning at the last 10
seconds so you know to wrap things up
and then please do stay on the line for
any questions
okay well firstly thanks for the
opportunity to put forward an objection
to this project
on behalf of many parishioners but in
particular those
are properties that are adjacent to the
area where it is proposed
to build the wheel play area whilst
there's been over
100 objections i appreciate that not all
of these are applicable at this stage of
the process
so i'm going to focus on the key issues
coming through from most of them which
is namely
noise and disturbance in its conclusions
of the noise survey the professional
company
the parish council eventually selected
mac acoustics
made clear recommendations in respect of
noise and disturbance
this is in section 6 page 14 conclusion
and i quote being reminded of the noise
policy statement for england which is
all reasonable steps should be taken
to mitigate and minimize adverse effects
on health and quality of life
while also taking into consideration the
guiding principles
of sustainable development therefore it
has been recommended that mitigation is
applied to reduce its risk
the most effective solution of which
would be a 2.5
meter high fence around parts of the
north east and west perimeter of the
skate park
constructiveness has shown that the
average noise levels and maximum noise
levels may reduce by
5 and 10 decibels they go on to say that
even with some form of acoustic barrier
which will only change a moderate risk
of an adverse impact into a minor risk
of an adverse impact for those homes
nearby
they finish with this statement
therefore mac acoustics
believes that the wider benefits to the
community should be considered
and that should not pose a constant
constraint
to achieving planning permission for
development provided the mitigation
measures here are followed other
sections that refer to households
keeping windows closed
etc however the acoustic barrier is the
critical area
and what is not ideal the barrier would
at least give those of us living near to
this proposal some form of protection
from the noise
and disturbance that the noise impact
assessment states will occur
this is most likely to happen when the
weather is clement and
residents are making use of their rare
gardens during spring and summer
the environmental health department of
sdc have stated they accept the report's
conclusions
this in my opinion would by implication
mean that they agree that some form of
acoustic barrier be put in place
they also state that due to the
averaging periods used noise levels
are unlikely to exceed the noise levels
that would be acceptable
if the properties were new well in this
instance we're not referring to new
homes
we're talking about properties that have
been there for decades all of whom
have objected on grounds of noise and
disturbance some parish councils
strongly opposed to the proposal
and even the community centre committee
objected worried about
impact on that in summary
we would like to see the application
declined however
if the committee are minded to give
approval to the project then as a
minimum
a condition should be the implementation
of the barrier around the park
to avoid noise and disturbance to houses
in the vicinity
as per the recommendations of the
specialist survey company
which have been accepted by stratford
district council environmental
health department thanks for listening
and we hope that our concerns are taken
account of
thank you very much mr george excellent
timing i think you're absolutely on the
button
uh do we have any questions uh from the
committee
can you just indicate in the chat please
the chat is quiet in which case uh mr
george thank you very much for your time
this evening much appreciated
thank you thank you okay we've got our
final speaker on this application which
of course is the award member councillor
o'donnell i
believe you're on the line that's
redundant yes good evening chair
welcome hello uh you know the routine of
course cancer donald you have five
minutes
um stay on the line at the end of the at
the end of your
end of your speech please over to you
thank you chair
and good evening this is going to be a
fairly short
presentation um eddington is a community
which pulls together
and this is highlighted by their
fantastic response to covid and the
continued support their community hub
offers to the residents of eddington and
full ready
and the world park area has been in
discussions as before i was a ward
member
it has had a lot of time and research
invested by the parish council and their
subcommittee with regular updates of
parish council meetings
and there is a goal within their ndp it
has already been discussed
to expand their sport and recreational
facilities within the neighborhood areas
there was also extensive engagement with
the youth community although this youth
community is now a little older and
there were queries raised at the
most recent parish council meeting as to
whether a skate park would still be
their desired community project but i
understand
that is not a planning reason i declare
that i'm actually neutral around this
project
so why have i brought this to committee
well as the applicant is the parish
council
and it was evident from the number of
objections on the portal and emails that
i've received
not everybody supports the project and
it was indeed evident from the parish
council at the start of the week
i thought the fairest solution for all
concerned was to bring this
to committee to yourselves i must raise
you that i am concerned regarding the
loss of an acoustic barrier
given that sound disturbance and noise
has been raised on a number of
objections
but i thank you for your time and
consideration committee
thank you so much appreciate it uh do we
have any questions for the ward member
i'll look to the chat for a second
please indicate if you have anything
right there's nothing i think in the
chat in which case counselor donald
thank you very much for your time
tonight
okay uh let's move then to
points of clarification from the
committee do we have any questions for
the officer
excellent so let's go to councillor
jennings first please
thank you chairman yes sir i just wanted
to raise
this issue which mr george's comments
about the
health officer um an sdc being an
agreement that a barrier would be useful
yet i don't really from what i
understand at the health for the
environmental health officer is okay
with it
just a bit of clarification there please
yeah um for clarity the
the environmental health officer
commented
essentially and i'm i have the comments
in front of me but i'm going to
summarize
that the noise will be audible it will
be
of a slightly different character to the
normal
background noise at the back and around
the park
but firstly the the levels
would only very occasionally exceed
that um ambient background sort of
for impact sounds and on average it
would
it wouldn't noticeably um
increase the the noise overall
um it's also not going to happen at
times
when or is unlikely to happen in any
great
um amounts at times when it will be most
offensive at night in other words um
and finally that that being the case he
did not consider
the fencing to be necessary um
that was in his second
set of comments specifically
he says i believe the noise impact would
not be significant enough to be a
barrier to development without the fence
as a worst case has been considered
in in the noise report that is and in
consideration of the context of the area
so it's sorry for just his final comment
was
if committee are minded to require such
a barrier it should be as specified in
the report so
it may be that there's some confusion
around that sentence but
that to me says that the barrier should
be the barrier
if you want it should be as specified in
the report
not another barrier thank you very much
okay thank you uh we go to council parry
for the next question please
thank you chairman um my questions
really along
similar lines um and if we were minded
to grant this application could there be
any conditions
that would reflect any monitoring um
of the noise and that if it reached um
excess decibels that then that would
need
there would be a need for a barrier to
be put in place really just
trying to give some reassurance to the
villagers
that's all
um i'm honestly gonna i would honestly
have to
come back to you on that one because um
i would need to consult ben to find out
what resources we have
monitoring not many i suspected
okay um have to i want to thank you
and finally uh captain legend
[Music]
thank you just a very quick one um about
the acoustic barriers or potential
acoustic barriers
i just wondered how transparent they are
or not
well that that is is the an issue that i
did want to raise
that the
acoustic fencing may obviously have a
positive impact on
noise but it has quite a negative impact
on
the visual environment on the aesthetics
of the area
so the answer is not very transparent
and if the committee are minded
to require offence then that would
change
the assessment of the proposal as a
whole because firstly
it would need to be erected outside the
current application site
which would require us to change the
um redline boundary restart the clock
reconsult
it would essentially be a new
application it would also require us to
assess
the aesthetic impact i have conducted
that assessment
sort of informally and i i don't think
it would be acceptable based on what
i've seen in the noise report
okay thank you that's that's interesting
um
there are no other points of
clarification in the chat
so if everyone's content i think you
move to the debate
excellent uh counselor harry do you want
to start is that
is that you indicating you'd like to
begin
yes that's absolutely fine chairman um
well i think the report is fairly
self-explanatory
um i think particularly we've got the
ndp
that the parish council has put forward
that has got
nearly well certainly 95 and a half
percent
support in the referendum um there are
no material planning reasons
to refuse this so my view would be to go
and propose
grant on this application
thank you uh i've got that seconded
immediately by peter richards uh
councillors do you want to speak on the
matter
only to second it formerly counts
thank you uh council edin you indicated
like to speak
sorry only really to make the point that
i think that there's a an offset of
putting barriers up
versus some of the other concerns about
um nuisance around the area that is
going to cut it off visually so
i'm also minded to go with councillor
parry and rich
thank you um right there's nobody else
indicating
to speak on this matter uh that's that's
something
that's rounded up i i think i agree with
what i've watched and said so far
uh i would say that i certainly do
understand um
residents concerns about noise i i get
it
but we've got to be we've got to stick
to what's in front of us on the
in the report and like uh councillor
parry said there are
absolutely no grounds at all for us
really i think to go against this
and not to mention the fact of course
the uh neighborhood plan
was backed by an overwhelming majority
of the people
of eddington so with that in mind i'm
gonna uh
go along with the officer's
recommendation so
nobody else wants to speak it's been
proposed and seconded uh that we
grant this application let's go to the
vote uh olivia if you're ready i'll kick
us off counselor kendall
four councillor richards
councillor richards iv councillor dixon
councillor dixon iv councillor eddon
councillor eddon for fitter
counselor fitter four councillor
jennings
councillor jennings ball and councillor
parry
councilman councillor parry four
that's unanimous chair thank you very
much liv uh okay so we're done with that
uh the in that case the committee uh
resolves to grant application reference
twenty slash zero one six zero six slash
f u
l uh live do we need to take a few
months to get the next speakers into the
next application
or are they ready um yes if we could
just have a little break
please that'd be great okay so say a uh
three or four minute break everybody
thank you
right [ __ ] oh i'm being told that we've
got the speaker in and we're ready to go
is everybody else ready should we go
back to meeting start again
okay we are back so we have speaker
waiting as well
let's move then to our next application
this is item five
and it's found on page 31 of your
agendas this is application reference
twenty slash zero one one four one slash
rem the site address is green ground top
street
north end uh the this is them forum
reserve matters application for
appearance landscaping layout and
scale the drawings to be constructed um
presenting officer is joe brooke
joe if you're ready to go over to you
thank you
let me just set up the presentation
i take everybody can see that perfect
lovely
brilliant the application site is
situated on the northern edge of north
end
as indicated by the black dot before you
the principal development for the three
dwellings within the application site
was established via planning appeal in
2019
as referenced within the officer's
report this application
is for all matters reserved except
access which was approved at the appeal
the application site is made of an
access point from top street
so this is top street heading in
situated between a house called green
ground as you can see
plan for your green ground and two
recently improved dwellings at reserve
matter stage in 2016
and these are now constructed and being
lived in as you will see
further into the presentation the
application is
for free two-story dwellings and
associated garages as indicated by a
layout plant so
plot one which is faces out into the
open countryside
situated to the already two state uh
dwellings
plot two which is coming in from green
ground into the site
and plot three and the associated
dwellings there as well
the dwellings would be set two stories
high with pitchers as well as front and
rear protruding gable elevations and
eaves
the dwelling is supposed to be
constructed out traditional stone with a
line based more to finish
red brick detailing would be provided to
the ease verges and chimneys
the main story height frames porch is in
conservatories and lintels are supposed
to be out of natural oak
the garages would be constructed out
natural stone with a red brick finish to
the eaves
matching the proposed weddings
these this is a street scene so
these are the two dwellings that i will
show you the photos of that already been
built
and the garage for the two reservoirs
this is the proposed
sites here so plot one as you can see
would represent the heights
and this is plot two situated just
behind so
no dominance in the officer's opinion
photo before you see the two recently
improved dwellings this is top street
heading into the
north end that's the garage says site
would roughly be around here
plot one's garage pot one plot two and
three situated just behind
this is heading out to north street and
that's the access point coming in that's
already been approved
so the rear of the properties this is
green grounds
and this is the application site so
you've got a side view
of the neighbouring properties as well
as green grounds here as well as the
royal residential dwellings
which is situated to the side of the
site within the village
and that's the end of the presentation
in consideration to the fact that the
application site was approved for free
dwellings at plan appeal in 2019
the application is considered complying
all relevant planning considerations
and is also considered not to cause
undue harm to locality or neighbouring
properties
thanks to
excellent thanks joe right let's uh
go to our first speaker uh councillor
james gordon coming please from uh
parish council
are you there please counselor
[Music]
welcome to the meeting so you have
three minutes to speak on this item um
we'll give you a warning at the last 10
seconds so you can wrap up
and uh if you stay on the line
afterwards so we
there may be some questions from the
committee okay okay
over to you then sir the 21
local service four villages in the
district are expected to deliver 400
houses
under the core strategy over 20 years
there's an average of 20 houses each
but these villages delivering 20 or so
houses over 20 years will almost
certainly be done in multiple small
developments
two here or there that is certainly the
case for north end
if we as a community are not able to
influence the types of houses that are
built in these small developments
then we are not able to influence the
future demographic of our community
twelve new houses have been approved in
north end since the course strategy was
finalized
eight of these were four bedroom
properties
we are now faced with a further
application seeking effectively three
more four bedroom size properties a
housing survey last year
highlighted a need for six two and three
bed housing
and bungalows for the elderly or
disabled the community has expressed
a need a material planning consideration
for smalling for smaller dwellings
if every new house that is built in our
village from now on as a four bed
mansion
what will this do to the diversity and
the variety that makes a community worth
this over time will have a detrimental
impact on the vitality of the community
another material planning consideration
when every developer seeks to maximize
the profits from every scrap of land
that secures outline planning permission
they will always default to building 700
thousand pound castles as people in my
community refer to them
and hang the impact on community they
don't care they don't live here
they only care about their bottom line i
live here
we live here and as paris and district
councils it is our job to arbitrate on
behalf of our communities
look into their long-term vitality their
long-term needs
and not allow each decision to be taken
in splendid isolation
if we do not influence the types of
houses built in this village
then who else will there are few enough
building plots in our village so each
one is valuable
a valuable opportunity to mould the
demographic of the community
today we decide on what happens to the
fourth plot in the village that
accommodates multiple houses
the previous three provided between them
eight four bedroom houses
two thirds of all the houses built in
the core strategy period
the course strategy suggests fifteen to
twenty percent of houses should be four
bedroom
not two-thirds allowing this application
will mean
three-quarters of the new houses in the
village will have been four-bedroom
at what point are we preparing now from
the community
at what point are we the parish council
and the community permitted to say
enough thank you
thank you very much ken so much
appreciated do we have any questions
from the committee for the parish
council please if you indicate in the
chat
the chat is quiet in which case uh
counselor thank you very much for your
time tonight it's very much appreciated
thank you thank you okay uh
we go to our ward member now on this
application which is councillor kettle
uh nazi are they our councillor kettle
excellent welcome to tonight's meeting
so routine you have five minutes um
please stay in the meeting at the end of
your time so if there are any questions
we can ask them at that point
councillor kettle over to you thank you
mr chairman
um yes good evening uh this is a
in um a parishes view a a contentious
application um and the chairman of the
parish council has clearly set
out the reasons why uh and i completely
understand
that position um and it is i think a
failing of course strategy
um that by allowing
multiple small applications to go
through
you can have the imbalance that um
the chairman has referred to the
difficulty is i'm not sure in the core
strategy
um we actually have a policy we do have
a policy on housing mix
but that refers to much larger
applications
um there is an allocation to four
three two and single beds
um or single single bedroom houses
rather
um so i'm absolutely behind where
um james is coming from
but it's just a you know we don't have
the tools and the core strategy i
believe
to turn around to a developer through on
the three house application and turn
around and say
your allocation is
is wrong because i believe and i'm sure
the officer will confirm this
uh if you wish to go through a challenge
about the points of clarification but
i'm not quite sure
under the policies whether we can
actually determine
on a three house application how that
mix should be
um but it is something i think we need
to take forward in any review of the
core strategy
how we do deal with in smaller uh
villages um ensuring there are an
adequate supply
of two and three bedroom houses
regretfully i don't think we have that
tool today
um so i'm sort of sitting on the fence
here really
because i understand one side and i
understand the other side
um there's no reason why the developer
without
that restraint should be required
to profile his housing mix
to a policy that the parish council
would want to see but doesn't actually
exist
i think that's probably all i've got to
say mr chairman you might be relieved to
hear
probably well within my five minutes
that's wonderful thank you very much
councillor kettle appreciate that
um do we have any questions for the
award member
there's nothing in the chats yet i'll
give it a moment see if anything appears
nope nothing coming up in which case uh
councillor kettle thank you very much
for your time tonight much appreciated
thank you um right we've we've finished
with our speakers on this application so
um do we have any points of
clarification from the committee
uh for for joe if you want to indicate
now please
or not there we go we've got one uh
councillor jennings
over to you well this is going to be a
surprise question
but is there anything which stipulates
that a mix of of three houses that there
has to be
um a certain stipulation of whether it's
one bedroom two bedroom four bedrooms or
whether it's
they can do what they want um there's a
few considerations fundamentally
no then the reason being is because the
mppf specifically states that viability
is a main consideration
for sites so on larger schemes
you can demonstrate that quite
significantly whether it's viable or not
for the developer
secondly the mppf actually requires a
full
housing mix of about 10 units more
actually in the core strategy on
local service villages required up to
six so it's actually less
than what the mppf suggests so this is
only three so even makes even harder to
acquire for anything regarding a full
housing or a lower tenure in the mix
also i should highlight the developer
requirements spd
although it does state about there's no
provision of four-bedroom dwellings
throughout the district it also states
that um
smaller market homes will enable more
people to access their home ownership
but on smaller sites it may not be
practical
for households to be listed under cs
so the honest truth is a sightless size
with three dwellings
we can't say to the developer no you
cannot have four bedroom dwellings on
this side
it's it's not a big enough scheme
excellent that makes it very simple
thank you yeah thank you for the for
that explanation
right if there are no other points of
clarification should we go to the debate
on this one
who who would like to start
thank you counselor jennings carry on
um i can see no material planning
reasons to object to this application
are therefore like proposed to grant
this application
uh i agree i'm happy to second that one
that
it's it's unfortunate but yeah i think
there are
some holes in the core strategy and you
know
if we can review it in future you know
we'll see what can be done but of course
it will be the uh
nppf which also comes into that as well
or whatever that turns out to be
in the next few months and years so um
it's a bit well i think i picked council
oranges i think i managed to second it
for once on this one so there we go it's
been proposed and seconded
there's nobody else who wants to speak
on this item which doesn't look like it
uh let's go to the let's go to the vote
on this um
uh live if you're ready to go with that
i'll i'll kick us off councillor kendall
four richard richards
directions for councillor dixon
councillor dixon for councillor
council reading four councillor fitter
councillor fitter four councillor
jennings
councillor jennings for counselors and
councillor parry
councillor parry four that's unanimous
jam
thank you lib okay in that case the
committee therefore resolves to
uh grant application reference twenty
slash zero
one one four one slash r e m
uh should we take a two minute break
will we bring in
the next speakers thank you
two or three minutes
up
okay i think we're back then we can
ready to restart the meeting please
okay we're back then uh okay i'll just
double check immediately
what's being said on the side here right
so we can go to our
first speaker i believe we should have
uh
peter taft as it please from sanborn
parish council
are you there mr chair yes i am can you
hear me
excellent thank you okay in that case mr
chaff
uh from the parish council if you i
don't know if you've seen the
proceedings so far you have three
minutes
uh to speak uh we'll give you a warning
in the last i think either
i think 30 seconds uh give you just a
little bit of time to wrap up your
thoughts
and then if you stay on the line for any
questions the committee may have at the
end of that
okay has the case officer already
presented the planning application
yes we've seen the presentation already
okay brilliant
okay thank you good evening
i haven't presented yet why am i talking
oh good god i am so
sorry hold on my mind is absolutely all
over the place
i'm sorry mr tap and the members of the
committee and everybody else let me just
humbly apologize for being a total [ __ ]
all right let's start that again we do
need to go with the presentation
first don't we maybe i've been doing
this a little bit too long as it turns
out right okay let's go to the
application reference that'll be a good
idea so that's item six
right i don't know if you tell how red
i'm going on the screen there so
okay that's uh application reference
then
twenty slash zero one one eight three
slash
f u l and the site address is ye old
barn
the green sanborn this is for the
erection of a one bed granny alex
in lieu of an egg stand garage and
associated works including the removal
of the caravan
and storage container in that case we
can go to our presenting office
zoya over to you
thank you chair um can everybody see the
slide
we can thank you um
right the application now before members
uh is for a detached annex building
within the garden
of the property known as yi old bond
the application site is identified by
this block dot
and it's located in the village of
sanborn
here the application site is outlined in
red
the main dwelling um is here
and is also shaded in red because it's a
it's a grade two listed building
um this conservation area is identified
by this pink line
and the other list of buildings within
the conservation area also
shaded in red there the green hash line
shows the
public right of way which adjoins the
application site
along its southern boundary
here we have the existing and proposed
site plan uh
to the left of this to the left of the
slide is the existing
site plan the main dwelling is here this
l-shaped structure
next to this is a garage which was
converted to an annex
there's a link between the main dwelling
and the annex
which isn't shown on this plan the
location of the approved garage
the previously approved garage is here
uh this was granted approval in 2004 um
there was a structure also here
previously which is which is no longer
there um the access to the site is
from here and would remain as existing
and no changes are proposed there
moving on to sorry moving on to the
proposed
site plan um
so this is where the annex is going
um over there
so here we have the proposed elevations
and floor plans
uh as seen in the renovation drawings
the annex will be single story picture
of structure
the front elevation uh central entrance
door with windows on the
other side they also doors which provide
access
to the garden the floor plan shows is
shows one bedroom a kitchen diner and
living room
[Applause]
that's been provided
so this is the approved plans for the
previous permission for the garage so
2004 approval
as you can see it's in a similar
position to the proposed annex
it's externally as timber
weatherboarding
and plain clay tiles on the roof and a
single garage door
this was smaller compared to the
proposed annex
now we'll move on to the photos
relevant to the application first image
it shows
the view from the drive here you can see
the
location of the approved garage
on the side there there's a caravan on
site
it doesn't have planning permission uh
but i understand has
has been there for for some for some
time
this image is panning to the right of
the last image here you can see
the garage is going there there's a
storage container on site
and it's used to store materials
for the applicant's business use the
container also doesn't have planning
permission
this is the view from the garden looking
towards the house that's the main house
there
this is the link between
the house and the garage conversion
that's here
this image is taken from the green so uh
that's our site over there um you can
see the roof of the existing building
and that's the view from the street
moving on to the last image here this is
taken from outside the site
this is the public right of way you can
see
the garden and some domestic
paraphernalia there so there are views
from the public right of way into the
site
that brings us to the end of the
presentation
so there's two updates for members
one is response to a technical question
from councillor dixon um it's included
within the update sheet
so we're recommending refusal for this
application for the reasons stated
within the officer report
that's all chair
oh gosh i'm sorry i'm having a few
connection issues tonight apologies
thank you very much uh the uh just very
quickly before we go to the speakers um
i thought the technical questions for
the next application actually took
uh for council dixon but i think don't
worry because zello
sorry my mistake you're right we're
that's fine don't worry about it um
right you know what let's do some
speakers so if we go this time to our
first speaker
uh peter taft from the parish council of
sanborn
mr taff are you there this time i am
yesterday i'm here
wonderful many apologies again um you
have three minutes
if you remain on the line at the end of
that three minutes uh for any questions
over to you sir thank you uh good
evening my name is peter taft from
sanborn parish council
i'm speaking tonight in support of the
annex building at the old barn for green
sanborn
we know the family they are well known
local family living in the village for
over 30 years
the parents of the applicant couldn't
live in the old barn
the applicant is their son he his wife
and their young child
currently live in the mobile home
located adjacent to the old barn
if this planning application is accepted
the parents of the applicant will move
into the annex
and the applicant and his young family
will take up residence in the old barn
therefore keeping three generations of
family together
which would certainly benefit the
parents as they head towards retirement
the current mobile home arrangement is
not sensitive
and the use of permitted garages to
justify small annex accommodation for
the parents is welcomed
as it allows the children their young
family to move into the main house and
provide the parents
with their own accommodation but one
would is linked to the main house
by condition a garage in this location
has already been approved the proposal
is not much bigger
and is sympathetic in design it would
cause no harm to the green belt or
setting
of the listed property whilst the old
barn is in the conservation area
the proposed uh the proposal is right on
the boundary and in our opinion
not seen from the village green if you
look at sanborn parish plan page 29
this shows sanborn conservation area
within the plan it shows a previous
building located in this very same spot
there's a proposal the previous building
was a nissan hut
which was demolished due to it deemed to
be unsafe
the original concrete base is still in
place
the proposed new building is far more
sympathetic to its surroundings than the
nissan ever was
we are pleased that under the planning
application the steel container which
has been on site since 2003-4
will be removed along with the mobile
home
which will add to the visual impact in
the greenbelt area once both these items
are removed
i would ask the planning committee to
look favourably on this application that
causes no harm or detrimental impact on
the village
which is why this application has the
support of sanborn parish council
thank you chair
do we have any questions please from the
members of the committee if you'd like
to indicate in the chat
no there's nothing coming up here in
that case mr chaff thank you very much
for your time this evening it's much
appreciated
it's a pleasure thank you thank you okay
we'll get to our next speaker
um to confirm we should have uh mr gary
moss
agent for the applicant mr moss are you
there yes chairman can you hear me okay
we can indeed that's excellent thank you
mr moss same
same rules apply three minutes and uh
please stay on the line at the end uh
just for any questions from the
committee
over to you thank you chairman uh my
client and his young family are
currently residing in a caravan
on site and have been for around three
or four years the current situation is
not sustainable
and the decision was made to create a
permanent annex for their parents on the
site of an extent
garage approval this would allow my
client and his family to move into the
main house
turn to the reasons for the refusal
independent dwelling
the annex like the caravan would have
water electric and gas
supplied directly from the main house
hence only one set of bills
drainage would also be discharged into
the existing sewage system
there is also no splitting up of the
domestic cartridge and the same vehicle
access would be used
it is disappointing that as part of the
application the case officer never asked
us to provide information clarification
on this point
the annex although offering the parents
their own independence would remain an
extension of the main house
and the condition is recommended to be
imposed to secure this
of note members should be aware that if
the garage were to be built
it could under policy as10c of the core
strategy
be converted into an open market
dwelling we consider this to be a
genuine and realistic format position
but one which would not allow control to
remain as an annex
to the main house secondly greenbelt
the site is in the greenbelt and located
on the footprint of an extant garage
although larger it remains of a size
which is clearly ancillary to that of
the main house
the increased pitch was only to allow
use of traditional plain clay tiles
the development would remove a caravan
from the site this itself
measures 12 meters by four and a half
meters
and a large steel container itself
measuring six meters by two and a half
meters
the container has been on site since
2003 and through the passage of time
remains a lawful um structure
the removal of the container alone
reduces the impact on the openness of
the green belt
significantly and compensates for any
increase in the size of the amex above
that of the extant approval
finally on this point i would inform
members that the client submitted an
amended plan hopefully the officer will
have this on screen for you
this proposed a smaller annex only 8
meters long not 10 meters long
and another simplified design
unfortunately this was refused to be
accepted by the officer as an amendment
three heritage impact as stated extent
permission remains for a garage on this
location and provides a genuine fallback
position
furthermore to enhance the setting of
the list of building and conservation
air
and as quoted by the parish council we
would seek the removal of the mobile
home and also this
contained from the site as previous
stated amend
an amended plan was submitted but
refused to be accepted addressing the
conservation of
concerns in conclusion we respectfully
ask that members approve the application
or at the very least consider the
revised plan before you
as submitted to the council and
potentially look to defer the matter
for further consideration of this
and then return the matter to committee
if necessary thank you very much
chairman
okay thank you very much uh mr moss do
we have any questions
uh from the members of the committee
please
i don't appear to be any coming up there
in which case mr moss thank you very
much for your time tonight
thank you very much thank you uh
we go then oh you know actually sorry
council edin you're
not registered to speak so in that case
we um go to points of clarification
uh for the officer please anything do we
have any
counselor jennings
thank you chairman um just wanted a bit
of clarification here
um an annex needs to be linked will have
dependence on the main house
is that correct yeah that's right um
it can be in the form of a physical link
or
a functional um so in this instance
we've got
an annex entirely self-contained
they are instances where they have they
share a kitchen
or other facilities or
a functional link in terms of they may
share
meals in the main house there just needs
to be some evidence of
a connection to the main house
for it to be considered as a nanics
thank you okay uh councillor parry
you're next
thank you chair i was going to pick up
on it on a similar point as councillor
jennings
um that obviously if this came
came back to committee um highlighting
the accommodation that there would be
shared space in the main house then
what you're saying is that it would be
considered
appropriate as an annex the other
question i wanted to ask
was the applicant highlighted a former
missing
heart and obviously we've seen in the
pictures that have taken
that the foundations of that nissan hut
are still there because it's got that
concrete base
does the proposed um structure
uh represent a replacement building
when you've got the foundations of a
previous building
still in situ
um the first question about
it um being if it came in
showing that link with the with the main
house
um i think it was it's it's a matter of
fact factor degree i think the evidence
uh
needs to needs to come forth for us to
to consider and take
a look at and i think um
that's not the only issue here it's
in terms of the conservation aspect and
the building isn't considered it doesn't
appear as an ancillary building
and hence it harms the setting of the of
the listed building what was approved
previously was uh was a smaller garage
it had
the appearance of an ancillary building
as well
in terms of its materials was
less dominant um so i think there's
there's other things to consider in
addition
um to the fact that um it's
we don't consider it to be um
ancillary um currently
um and i think that this the second
point about
uh the shelter that was there previously
the garage was
approved in 2004 because it was
considered to be an improvement from
that
um it was going to get rid of um
a poor structure and put in its place
um something that was considered to be
better
it had in appearance reflected
um he reflected i think the conservation
officer mentions in the report um
the bus shelter on the green so it had
some um
some relevance to to the wider
conservation area and reflected
its character what we've got here
is quite a dominant structure
which which which would harm the setting
of the list of building and the
conservation area
i don't have plans of the previous
structure that was there
um i'm going based off of the
um the site plan that's been provided at
the moment
so i think we would need to to look at
the
the difference in the size um and and
make that comparison
okay uh thank you we go to uh councillor
dixon next please for a question
uh thank you chairman not so much
question a request um
could we have those pictures please of
ye old barn because essentially
i'm getting the distinct impression that
what is being proposed is a fairly
domestic
21st century brick building etc
whereas the garage that has extant
permission was if you like
more of a rural uh agricultural feel
etc and more keeping with the old barn
and therefore i would like to see the
images please and i did wonder
i must have had just obviously part of
the old barn is 17th century but the
pictures did seem to be
decidedly far more modern than that and
it wonder if the extensions are
more dominant than the original listed
and whether there is something to be
protected
or not i also have some concerns as to
the
enforcement or possibly lack of
enforcement as to whether the caravan
and that container should even be on
site it sounds as though the container
has been there more than 10 years so
we've probably
lost the opportunity there but should
the caravan have been removed
sorry sorry i think you're muted at the
moment
yeah um in terms of the caravan being
there for 10 years i think that's a
matter that would need to be addressed
by a lawful development certificate
application
uh the container and the caravan
don't benefit from planning permission
um
and as they are harm the character
of the listed building and this green
belt harm as well um
so i don't i don't think that that forms
an argument um
and and the lawfulness of that would
need to be established by a separate
application
in terms of the other pictures could we
have those up again and maybe
just give a bit more information for
council dixon
that possible
so i said this picture that you wanted
to
see councillor dixon yes
essentially the uh the the previous one
so that's that that's the caravan
yeah we're told that some of the family
have been living in for three or four
years so i don't know if that's
even suggested it's been there for 10
years yet but the the previous slide
please
uh yeah right
yeah obviously the i take it the timber
framed one is obviously the old barn
which is
slightly obscured and then we've got
quite a large extension which was the
garage that was previously converted to
an annex and then the link
which looks decidedly modernish and
presumably what is now proposed
is more akin to that than the old barn
structure
yes that that's right thank you
okay excellent thank you for that
everyone um
i'm not dale's suggesting that maybe we
go to meena just for a bit more
clarification regarding um i think
you're talking about probably the lawful
development certificate
of dale uh meanwhile would you be able
to comment on that a little bit more
in terms of the um uh current situation
regarding the
container and the caravan sure
um in terms of any um unlawfulness of
the caravan on site as sawyer mentioned
that would be
dealt with via a separate process which
is the lawful development certificate
process and there's an application form
and process to go through for that
um in terms of enforcement generally
of the caravan um enforcement by the
council is discretionary
and so it would be up to the council um
depending on the circumstances whether
to take enforcement action or not
um without knowing the detail i'm not
sure
whether that's been done or what stage
that might be at
um in this case but i think that's
outside
any enforcement action would be outside
of the scope of this particular
application
so it's not what we're looking at here
thank you for that clarification very
much appreciated brilliant
right um are there any other points of
clarification or should we go to the
debate so we have to get to the debate
on this now
anybody want to start
thanks councillor parry thank you
chair um well obviously i have every
sympathy with the applicants they're
trying to sort of
um improve their own domestic situation
um but unfortunately we have um
a very comprehensive report we have the
green belt
policies um and in particular we also
have the um setting
of the grade two listed main
dwelling which is certainly impacted by
this
um it's therefore you know as i say i do
understand the difficulties the
applicant has and their wish to create a
um an environment for
um two generations of their family to
live but unfortunately
what we have in front of us in my view
um doesn't conform to policy um
and therefore i will be going with the
officer's recommendation to refuse
thank you councillor parry uh councillor
you've indicated
an indication
thank you chairman very similar thought
saying
sympathy for the family and their
accommodation
and their wish to have more space and to
keep all the generations together
this application's for an annex and it's
clearly not an annex
it seems to me it's it's the wrong
application
um so i would be certainly agreeing with
the
officer on this one um and i'm not sure
if uh
councillor parry was proposing
um to make a proposal there if she was
then i will second it if not
then i'm quite happy to um
to make proposal that we refuse this
application
thank you council jennings i don't think
i heard any proposal so we'll take it as
read that
council jennings you are proposing a
refusal and i see the council of harry
has now seconded in the chat
so that's excellent thank you um right
so
uh counselor editor would you like to
speak
thank you only really to sympathise as
well it's a very common sense approach i
think that
the applicant is trying to take and for
me
the harm that even this application
would cause
doesn't um outweigh the harm that's
currently in place with the container
and the
caravan but um i think
i think we know which way this is going
to go based on the
um when is an annex not an annex
conundrum
so i think i'm going to have to follow
the
officer's recommendation on this one as
well unfortunately
okay thank you counselor um so i'm not
seeing anybody else wishing to speak on
this
it is unfortunate i'll have my thoughts
yeah i obviously do feel for the family
it would be lovely if we could help
every family and every family of course
has special circumstances and things
they want to do but
this is against policy and i can't find
any reason for us to
uh go against certain policy on this so
i'll have to join the rest of the
committee by the looks of it and uh and
refuse
um it's been proposed by council
jennings that we refuse the application
that was seconded by councillor parry
nobody else we should speak i think liv
if we go to the vote i'll kick off uh
councillor kendall
four councillor richards for
councillor dixon councillor dixon for
councillor eddon
councillor edin unfortunately four
councillor fitter councillor
councillor jennings councillor jennings
paul
and councillor parry councillor parry
four
that's unanimous again thanks love
okay so the committee therefore resolves
to refuse application reference twenty
slash
zero one one eight three slash ful
um we move to our next item i think we
just have a couple moments to bring in
the
speaker for this one as well simply just
take the pause for two or three minutes
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
okay i think we're ready to reconvene we
have our speaker waiting as well
okay everyone let's continue the meeting
lovely
okay uh let's have the presentation this
time shall we right application
reference
uh this item seven application reference
twenty slash
zero one one six three slash ful
um the this is for uh pendique
danzig green lane danzig green and is
for the demolition of existing dwelling
and outbuilding and the erection of a
replacement dwelling
uh case officer zoya again is it over to
you
thank you chair um can everybody see the
slides
not yet
so can everybody see now yes thank you
before we go on just let me just say
this to the committee just to know that
council dixon
is stepping down from the committee so
he can speak as ward member on this one
just to clarification apologies for that
zoya over to you
thank you chair um the application now
before members
is for a replacement dwelling um
for an existing dwelling known as
pendique uh the application site
is identified by the black dot here uh
and it's located within
dancy green
here we have the existing plan for the
site the site's outlined in red
um the dwellings uh
and the dwelling in the associated
buildings are shaded
in grey over here uh it's located with
in within a row of
other dwellings set back from dancing
green lane
there's a number of trees on site which
are shown on the plan here as well
but none of these are are protected
so i'm moving on to the existing
elevations which can be seen
at the top of this slide here
the existing house is is two-story with
a large single story
side projection it has four bedrooms as
you can see on the floor plans
all at first floor uh the single story
elements
are two drawing rooms and orangery um
below the main house plans here um are
the
existing plans for a detached
outbuilding
that's located adjacent to to the house
here we have the proposed site plan um
the existing access from danzig green
lane um
will be used no changes are proposed
there
the position of the dwelling will be
similar to the existing house
a step back from from the highway the
detached
sun room which is here is proposed to be
removed
however the detached building a garage
building here
is proposed to be retained
here we have the proposed elevations um
as you can see a um a three-story
dwelling is is proposed
um the basement level isn't visible
here on the elevation plan so above
ground you just see two stories
um there'd be single story side and rear
projections
as well uh the design of the new
dwelling um
will be quite different to the existing
more in arts and crafts style
with lots of mark tudor detailing that
can be seen there
there'd be views of the house through
the existing access
um
these are the first floor plans so here
you have the basement
the ground floor and the first floor
there's a total of six bedrooms that are
proposed
here we've got a visual comparison
between the
current proposal um that could be seen
at the bottom here
and the extent permission on site um
the top the top drawing there is the
approved front elevation
um and this is a visual of how it would
look uh
as you can see it has a main two stories
section there
and a single story side relevant but
overall it's a relatively modest
structure
um the bottom drawing here
um there's no visual that's been been
provided however
by comparison um it it it appears as a
larger dwelling um
than the then the extant permission and
even the existing
um existing dwelling on site
um moving on to the images so this is
the view from danzig green lane
and that's the access and the dwelling
can be seen over there
it's a closer image of the dwelling so
this is the two-story section here and
you can see
some of the single story drawing rooms
there
this is taken from the front of the
dwelling in from the lawn
and it just gives a different
perspective of the existing house
so this is the last image and it's taken
from the rear garden
um so the dwelling can be seen down here
and there's there's quite a significant
significant increase in in levels as you
move towards the rear of the garden
that's the end of the presentation um
so we have two updates for members um
first one is um councillor dixon
technical question and the response to
that um
that's been included within the update
sheet um
so chairman we've recommended to refuse
this application
for the reasons stated in in the officer
report
that's excellent thank you very much
excellent let's go to our first speaker
on this application this is the
agent for the applicant uh donna savage
donna are you there please
hello you you need to press star six to
unmute yourself i think
hello hey hello
fantastic thank you no worries so you
have three minutes to speak uh and
address the committee
we'll give you a warning in the last 30
seconds so you can you can wrap up
and um if you stay on the line for any
questions from the committee at the end
thank you for allowing me to address the
committee this evening this case is
about harm to openness of the green belt
previous approvals have agreed the
amount of footprint and volume that can
be built on the site
and to be clear this application does
not exceed what could be built on the
site either by extending under pd
or building the dwelling that we've
already got approval for
what this application does is
reconfigure the footprint
and the volume already approved to allow
for a more usable dwelling for my client
the proposal effectively takes footprint
and volume from the rear
as shown on plan 11 which we submitted
and adds it to the side it is important
to note that the proposed dwelling is no
wider than the existing dwelling
and in fact due to the removal of
existing outbuildings
development does not extend as far
across the site
as is currently the case the report
describes
the approved dwelling as two-story with
a single-story side element
i would like to point out that the
dwelling as approved and now proposed is
not a full two-storey
with two floors and a roof and in fact
the first floor is actually contained
within the roof space
the single storey element referred to is
in fact only 700 millimeters lower than
the main roof
as it was a room with a vaulted
the proposed in front of you tonight
adds
700 millimeters in height to what the
report describes as that single story
element
and i was trying to think of how i best
could describe the difference in visual
terms between what has been approved
and what is now proposed and the
comparison i've come up with
relates to hot tubs and in effect we're
adding two family sized hot tubs
to the side of what has previously been
approved and i will reiterate
those hot tubs if you like have been
moved from the rear to the side
the case officer under heading principle
of development
concludes that it would not be so
visually harmful to warrant refusal
and the principle of development is
acceptable
in line with policy cs20 the report says
the development would be
would not be particularly visible from
the road and can only be glimpsed from
the access
and i think you just saw that in the
photographs it appears to me we're
talking about perceived harm
rather than actual harm to the openness
of the greenbelt
i conclude that there is no additional
harm to the openness of the greenbelt as
there is no additional footprint and
volume proposed
this is simply a slightly different
elevation that does not
amount to demonstrable harm as of the
31st of august just gone
my client could now extend the two-story
element of this
dwelling upwards adding a further two
stories
under the new permitted development
rights this would undoubtedly cause harm
to the green belt
instead he would like to build a
traditional arts and crafts building
that would have that he already has
approval for
i respectively ask that you approve the
application as there is no harm to the
openness of the greenbelt
thank you
thank you for that excellent um do we
have
any questions thank you councillor harry
you're first please
thank you thank you chairman um and
thank you
and donna could you just advise
um and confirm what are the very special
circumstances in this particular case
that merit
overriding the green belt um policies
well first of all we disagree that
uh we need very special circumstances
this is a replacement dwelling
in accordance with policy uh through the
history you'll see that
various permissions have been granted
for side extensions
rear extensions etc which
would in fact make an already
higgledy-piggledy dwelling
appear even more higgledy-piggledy for
want of a better expression
so we've consolidated that footprint and
volume
and submitted an application for a
replacement dwelling
we subsequently having re-looked at that
design have redesigned
the same footprint and volume but just
in a different way
and in effect what we've done is shave
off a lot of
footprint and volume of the rear and add
it to the side
we have actually shown on plan 11
um an outline of the previous um
footprint um in comparison to this so
actually if sawyer is able to show that
um that actually quite clearly shows how
much is being taken off the rear
and added to the side so we say
that we are policy compliant
[Music]
okay thank you very much do you have any
other questions from the committee
the chat seemed quiet in that case donna
savage thank you very much for your time
tonight much appreciated
thank you thank you um okay
we have so if we could yes i'm sure we
can have the the
presentation to show the proposed
elevations in a second while we're doing
that it's okay thank you
uh shall we go to our ward member the
next speaker please
councillor dixon
you're on mute at the moment
i must have fixed it sorry i must have
kicked that one twice
don't worry you have five minutes you
know the routine over to you
thank you very much chairman uh i think
this is the third or the fourth uh
case that i've brought and supported
where the openness of the green belt
is the sole issue essentially as you've
just heard from
the agent this is an application which
is a resubmission of a previously
approved scheme
so i'm not looking at this in comparison
with the existing building
i'm looking at it in respect of the
approved scheme
which has already got uh approval as
such
and it's a question where about there's
no real increase in the volume
there's a reduction in the footprint
what the applicant
wants to do and what you've just heard
from the agent is basically to redesign
and reconfigure what has already been
approved into a more
appropriate and better looking building
in fact we have it that the attractive
arts and crafts style
dwelling and in terms of style would be
an improvement on the existing designs
on the site
certainly that is without a shadow of a
doubt
you can see from the size of the
property the size of the plot
that it is one of several along that
street
it probably has an acre of land i
suspect between its front and its back
and the space taken up by the
development itself
the planner indeed indicates that this
is a property which could be glimpsed
through
the open access we saw the view from the
gate you can hardly see the property
to actually add another 700 mill
to the top of that building is is
minimal
i think in terms of impact upon the
openness of the green belt
uh regarding design and distinctiveness
the
uh toya is satisfied that tree coverage
on the site would be maintained
the proposal therefore meets cs9 cs20 of
the course strategy
special landscape area indeed report
reading from the report the proposal is
therefore not considered to cause any
harm
to the distinctive character appearance
of the high quality landscape
of the quality of arden essentially all
we're talking about here is
can we glimpse this property through the
gateway
and are we dealing with a higher impact
upon the openness
of the green belt there is minimal
impact
on the volume there is a reduction in
the footprint
it is simply producing a better design
than that which they currently have
etc this application has my full support
analysis i hope that you will support
this application
and allow a far better design to proceed
thank you chairman thank you councillor
dixon
uh do we have any questions for the ward
member on this please
i'll give a moment for the chat
which is remaining quiet so i'll presume
we don't have any questions counselor
dixon thank you very much for that
thank you thank you chairman
right that was our last speaker so uh go
to points for clarification do we have
any questions for the um
case officer please
council richards hope to you
thank you chairman um i've got i've been
trying to go through as much of this as
i can
and compare with the the extent
permissions i'm confused as to
the the 271 square meters
that you refer to on the this is on the
community infrastructure of every
section
is the increase is that an increase in
internal floor area on the existing
or on the extant permission
is the increase in the floor area of the
existing
okay given there's an extent permission
why wouldn't we use that as the
increase is the extent they can build
out whenever they want
what do you mean sorry there's an extant
permission
yeah why wouldn't we use this the
increase
um on that permission
rather than the existing given that six
stands does that not take premises over
what's there now
no it's the additional floor space above
what's there at the moment
it's the figure that we quote over there
so the fact that it sticks stance is
irrelevant
yeah and could you give me the the um
change in square meterage from the
extent permission to this one because
i'm struggling to find that within the
um the report um let's find a split with
me
um
also is finding that information perhaps
i can
help councillor richards over the the
sil question
the existing permission
would be subject to a sill charge that
still charge hasn't been paid
that sill charge is calculated in
relation to the
original dwelling so as that sale charge
hasn't been paid it can't be discounted
for the proposed commission that they're
requesting now
does that make sense that that makes
sense
it makes perfect sense has been made
very clear thank you
sorry just bear with me that's okay
the increase in in the floor space for
the extant permission
is similar to to the existing
um quoted in the exit the current
application
um there's only a very very small
difference
um in in the um the
floor space um i think it's about
five five square meters
if that does it so just around clear
there's a total increase
of five square meters should this be
approved
over the extant permission
sorry could you repeat that i can't i
can't hear very well
that's okay um so just why i'm getting
this right and i'm clear
the there is an increase in five square
meters
should this application be approved over
the extent permission that has already
been approved yeah that's right
lovely that's what i need isn't it thank
you very much
thank you okay we'll go to another
question this time councillor harry
please
please thank you chair obviously with
the
um the new permitted development rights
um regulations that have come that have
become um apparent obviously they
they could add another um five meters to
the back
to the side and go up
double story um so if they did that to
the existing
to the current extant permission
can you just advise would that be more
than what they're actually currently
proposing in terms of the floor
square the footprint i think um
something like that would need to be
looked at by an
i'm sorry i think though council power
you make a good point
just visually you can tell that it would
be a lot more but i think
obviously zoya can't really go into that
country on this because it's a bit too
speculative
but yeah i think your point was made um
if i may can i can i see a little
clarification there
i'm not sure whether councillor parry
was talking about the
existing commission or the existing
dwelling
in her question if she's talking about
the existing commission
the answer is no you cannot add two
stories
to the existing commission as permitted
development it's specifically excluded
if you were talking about the existing
house then yes of course it can
okay that's excellent thank you jail
excellent uh really helpful okay
uh good clarification uh any other
questions please at this point from the
committee
okay so no i think so should we go to
the debates
anybody raring to go on this one
so i'm in two minds myself so i'm gonna
wait and see what other people are
thinking at this point
uh councillor parry you seem like
you're okay to do that well i was
waiting for somebody else to come wading
in on this one but
um i actually i think this is uh
they're always very challenging aren't
they when they're um
green belt and um looking existing
permissions
but on the face of it um i actually
can't see that the harm is substantial
against the green belt
um you know there's been a lot of
careful thought
on the reorganization in terms of the
design
i think the design actually enhanced
this the setting
of the green the green belt anyway
um and i i do not see the harm as being
significant so on this rare occasion on
agreed belt application
i'm actually going to go against the
officer's
recommendation and go for
grant on this particular one because i i
do not
feel that the the harm is substantial
um when you consider the the overall
footprint
and i think the design enhances
the actual setting over what is
currently
being proposed that's it from me
thank you councillor parry um i think
you have
you've several i was thinking i just
wanted to what if anybody else is going
in that direction i think it was
very helpful questions from both
yourself and uh council richards that
helped me with that one as well um
does anybody else want to see i'm not
sure if council parry has proposed
actually that we know you said you'd
rather go ahead you're happy to propose
thank you
i'll tell you that okay um
refused thank you i think we've got it
proposing that we we grant the
application from councillor parry
i see uh councillor fitter has jumped
into second council official would you
like to speak on the application do you
have anything to add
or yes sure um i completely agree with
um
council of paris comments there it is um
quite a difficult one to consider
um but i would like to second the
proposal
that we go against the officer's
decision and regret this
thank you council the federal will note
you seconding the application sorry the
proposal
uh caps richards before we go to you can
i just double check uh
dale zoya at this point because i think
we
can see which way it's going uh do you
have a set of draft
um conditions that would go along with
this and if not
if you're not going to sort those out
right now damn
i'm looking at zoya chair i don't think
we have a set of draft conditions we
don't
think we expected this at all
i think if they would be
possibly very much similar to the to the
previously approved application i'm
uh that's fine well perhaps if we use
those as a guide
the previously approved application and
then perhaps we can
if those can come back to the chairman
just to double check later
i'm not sure there's any other major
issues that people seem to be raising
that would add to those conditions so
you're probably right though that the
original conditions would be okay i
think
um dale's nodding as well um sorry
council riches can we go to you then
uh thank you chair um this i've been
wrestling with this all the way through
the presentations
um and the reason i asked about the the
uh size and scale and the increase was
to really get a full understanding of
the actual actuality of the
of the change um and and hearing five
square meters it doesn't sound
all that much however
i have i i'm now i'm now looking at the
size scale in bulk and comparing
the original proposed um
and extant permission front elevations
inside elevations versus the
elevations of the the proposed now um
the proposed now are demonstrably larger
and when we're talking about
the impact on green belt it's not just
about the
volume um it's it's about the size scale
and bulk as well
and in my mind having considered the
both sides and
i must admit when i as i say when i was
talking about the the square meter ridge
i was probably falling more on the side
of yourself and councillor parry but
actually
having now again once we've once again
reviewed the elevations
in my mind it's very clear that this
would have a significantly larger and
more harmful impact
on the green belt um and
with that because of that i'm going to
propose that we
do and i accept that there is a
proposing a second that will here first
but i am going to propose that we do uh
refuse
in line with the officer's
recommendation um for the reasons
that has been set out and as i've just
uh laid out
now thank you
oh okay thank you thank you for that
council richards um
we'll have to deal of course with the
with the what with the the proposal we
have first then we'll come back back to
that of course you know that um
councillor jennings um could
would you like to speak now thanks
chairman you know i mean this is all
this is all down to the perceived damage
and you can look at
to the green belt and it sort of almost
say well if you look at it from one
angle you may see it
that's causing damage if you're going
from a you're looking at it from a
around the side then if it's if it's not
going out as far
and it's is it doing as much damage
there
sort of i'm getting splinters from
sitting on the fence on this one
um and i continue to get splinters at
the moment
um dale suggested could we put the
proposed elevations up would that help
us by the way i've got them there
so from the rear from the rear
i can't see the damage it's
i'm struggling to see the extra damage
at the moment really struggling on that
okay thank you cats and jennings um we
go to council edin please
and then council riches thank you
um i'm see soaring on this one as well i
have to say it's a it's a tricky one
um but i think i'm i'm coming down on
the side of cancer
richards that is demonstrably bigger
and that's what's bothering me the harm
on the green belt so
if he needs a second later um
i'll happily second him
okay thank you council richards you
wanted to come back in
thank you chairman i do need a secondary
counselor eden so if uh i i feel willing
and nod
i think we'll probably accept that
second thing now of course we do have to
hear the first proposal first
um it might be worth us looking at
i think it's slide seven which compares
the extent permission to the current
um in my mind that that makes it very
clear
to me it looks twice the size
frankly um that is a demonstrably larger
physical being on site and
as i said before ultimately we're
looking at the size scale and bulk and
the impact this has
on the green belt and to have twice the
size of something that was already
reasonably large
um you know to my mind
it is very clear that this will have a
detrimental impact and a harmful impact
on
uh the on the green world
thank you council richards uh council
jennings is asking is there a side view
uh to show the comparison between the
extant and the current i'm not sure if
there is
actually so do you have one um i don't
have a comparison
um but i can i can
bring up the um i'll show the exist
thing first just here
so the side elevations
here the existing ones okay and
the whole side elevations are here
okay it is a tricky one it's it's
difficult on this
um i'm as from chairman's point of view
i'll say
that i think when it comes to these sort
of applications they are
extremely fighting about i think this is
one of those finally balanced ones to be
honest i don't think everyone recognizes
that
and that's why i think they tend to um
come to committee
and that's for us then to make the final
interpretation and that's what we're
here for
we've heard good arguments on both sides
of honest i
i i do come back to that one point which
was made earlier which is
taking the extant uh proposal out of the
out of the uh question if we were to
look at the existing elevations on
permitted development rights that could
go up a second floor
a second story right now
um under permitted development i believe
and then that would i think
they'd be as or would have the same
impact
as what's being proposed tonight in the
application
so if what i'm doing in my mind is
taking away the x down to the moment i'm
just looking at those two what's
existing
and what is proposed tonight nothing to
do with the extent and that's why i'm
i'm happy to go along with the
proposal by councillor parry
right i i feel that we i think we've
talked about it i think we're in danger
of
talking too much if there's anybody else
who wants to speak
in the debate right now please do
indicate
but otherwise i think we should probably
put this to the vote and see what's
happening and see what
and then maybe move on from there um
right if we're happy to do that uh the
proposal then has been it sorry is to uh
grant the application um it was seconded
by
councillor fitter it was proposed by
councillor parry uh
very very quickly before we go to any
vote uh dale and zoya you are you can
just nod at this one you're content that
we have enough
conditions if if this goes through
nod would do okay thank you that's right
okay chad can we just confirm the
reasons please
yes that's a good idea thank you um
i'll i think the reasons i've heard and
counselor parry i'll go back to you in a
second uh there's no
demonstrable harm from the new uh from
the
from the application before us tonight
or it is negligible
uh harm is that are you happy with that
sort of a word
the harm is not significant over the
existing
um thank you that's good
um are we happy with that uh should we
go to a minor
you content with wording there as well
as as um
yeah that's my mummy okay
right let's run through a vote on it and
see what happens um if you're
okay with that liv uh councillor kendall
four councillor richards against
councillor edin council redden against
councillor fetter councillor fitter
four councillor jennings
councillor jennings abstained sorry
still got splinters
and councillor parry councillor parry
four
chair that's three four two against and
one abstention
thank you liv okay well we have a
decision uh therefore the committee
resolves
to grant application reference twenty
slash
zero one one six three slash ful
um i think that brings us to the end
of our items tonight um
live do we have any urgent business do
we we don't know
right in that case let's wrap up the
meeting uh i think
this probably this is my last meeting as
chairman of the committee uh
i hopefully will be back maybe as a vice
chairman in the future but we'll just
see what happens at annual meeting next
week before we count that one
i'd just like to take this moment to say
thank you very much for everyone's help
officers you you as always absolutely
fantastic
brilliant absolutely brilliant um i've
thoroughly enjoyed being chairman and
that's
in no small part down to the fact that
we've got such an excellent committee so
thank you to all of you
it's been absolutely wonderful being
chairman and best of luck to council
richards who will probably be taking
over
that role in the future unless anybody
else has anything else
anything else to say tonight i think
we'll close the meeting
meeting closed then at 7 51.
thank you chairman i'd just like to say
thank you thank you dan